so I've started reading this amazing
book by Richard powers and in his book
he says the best arguments in the world
won't change a person mind the only
thing that can do that is a good story I
kind of agree with that because I've
actually been so I've been working on
climate change since 2004 and since this
entire time have been talking to lots of
different people and it's really hard
just to show data and show facts like
the the slides that I started off with
with my talk today that usually doesn't
change people's minds especially if
their minds are already made up so I
think stories are really important Neil
Gaiman actually gave a talk at the Long
now and he basically says all good
stories change you and I think that's
really powerful all good stories do
change us but sometimes we don't know
how they changed us and sometimes the
change takes place like way way way into
the future so I'm trying to figure out
how to deal with that so people don't
act in terms of how do you so what type
of action and I'm trying am I trying to
get at we need a price on carbon I think
all if all of us will agree with that we
really need a price on carbon right now
and so we need public support for a
price on carbon and Washington state a
strike starting to do that we need to
change individual behavior as well that
reflects our new transition pathway that
we're trying to get to and so a lot of
my past work has looked at facts and
feelings separately I've sort of kept
them separate and I've been toggling
between both of them because looking at
them together makes things really really
messy so what I've looked at is how do
people understand what is most effective
for them to change in their own lives so
if I were to ask you today what is the
single most effective thing you can do
to decrease your energy consumption
would you know do you want to shout out
some answers don't have kids don't eat
meat don't fly don't fly
electric cars food waste all right so we
have a really good list I'm going to
show you what the modal responses in the
United States you're gonna be really
surprised and then I've also been
looking at how do you change social
norms how do you get people to pay
attention to this problem because
attention is actually a very limited
resource so think of attention is like a
very small pond of
that you carry with you everywhere you
go and every time someone asks for
something you like giving them a little
bit of that water and then you're like
I'm gonna go eroded my water go I need
to go and back into my cave so that's
what attention is it's just it's a
serious limited resource so I asked you
this question in your opinion what is
the most effective thing here are the
responses that we get since the 1980s
this has been the number one modal
response that people get people give to
this open-ended question what is the
single most effective thing the modal
response of starting with will it
Kempton in the 1980s has been turning
off the lights and this is when you ask
people very broadly hey what is the
single most effective thing very similar
to what I asked you
however a surprising finding for my work
that I'm not gonna show you but I'll
talk to you about it for a second is if
you ask people what is the single most
effective thing other Americans can do
do you know what the answers are all of
the ones that you told me it's a
carpooling getting an efficient car go
getting an electric car biking instead
of driving so the answers really change
so it's not that people don't know what
is effective is that they don't want to
do those behaviors themselves
I'm telling you more challenges than
solutions so turning off the lights is
great please do that but it's not the
most effective thing yeah you guys you
guys know already so I also you know
given my training in physics and in
engineering I was really interested in
how do people quantitatively estimate
how much energy different appliances use
so if I were to ask you do you know what
the difference is between a watt and a
watt hour do you guys know you guys know
okay two hands went up do you guys know
yeah three hands went up okay
all right a couple of guys in the back
and there's a friend saying yeah he
knows but he okay they're all pointing
at each other so a lot of people do not
know what a watt and a watt hour is
right so they don't know what the units
of energy are so what I wanted to
understand is if I were to ask people
about different appliances in their
homes how well do that can they
understand how much energy different
appliances use just broadly so what I
first had to do and over here on the y
axis you have Percy
energy used or saved in watt hours and
on the x-axis you have actual energy
used or saved in watt hours this is a
log-log scale so it goes from one ten
hundred so on and so forth so data that
lies along the diagonal line means
people's perceptions match reality okay
so what I said was all right imagine a
hundred watt light bulb a hundred watt
light bulb being left on for an hour
uses a hundred units of energy now how
many units of energy would your
dishwasher use would you guys be able to
kind of yeah in the same amount of time
in one hour so that was like the type of
question I asked people I would I want
but I won't put you on the spot I'll
just show you the data so I told
everyone all right a hundred 100 watt
light bulb uses a hundred units of
energy how many units of energy with
these different appliances use so in
general the orange line is the overall
curve but I'm gonna walk you through it
with some examples so a laptops are
overestimated by a factor of two so
people think it's equivalent to one
light bulb when it's actually equivalent
to half and this is data from 2009 so
now laptops are becoming way way way
more efficient changing the washer
setting from hot to cold actually is
underestimated by a factor of 40 so
people think changing from hot to cold
is equivalent to saving one light bulb
when it's actually equivalent to saving
40 lightbulbs so this is the entire set
of appliances that we looked at and so
what you notice is that when you start
using a lot of energy when you start
thinking about appliances that use a lot
of energy there's a huge underestimation
a lot of this data is below the diagonal
line not just that people are not able
to correctly differentiate between these
appliances so there's this compression
bias so what we really need to do if we
are thinking about energy use is we need
to take that curve and pull it up
towards the diagnol how do we make
people accurate then there's the other
question which I hope you guys will ask
me is that does accuracy matter if we
have limited effort and I would say yeah
it does if people think that you know
some of these ineffective behaviors are
really effective and they're not that's
really problematic so what we does
anyone have accurate perceptions so we
asked this is disclaimer to
we asked two electrical engineers and
they're really accurate so engineers
yeah we're awesome so engineers do
really well on this task and so what we
did was we tested a manufactured
heuristics let me walk let me break that
down and what that means a heuristic is
basically a rule right so I can give you
a rule to enact a particular behavior a
manufactured heuristic is a manufactured
a rule that I give you to use when
you're making a decision so if I were to
tell you large appliances that heat and
cool use a lot more energy than you
think that actually is a heuristic that
if you're making your energy estimates
that actually pulls that curve up
towards the diagonal so I'm not teaching
you what the difference is between watts
and what hours I'm not telling you how
to compute how much energy different
appliances use I'm just giving you a
very simple rule what be so that's what
the heuristic condition is right here so
you can see the baseline basically
replicates the original data the
heuristic condition bumps the slope up
and then if I give you multiple anchors
so I just gave one light bulb in the
first condition but if I were to give
you like an LED and I get and I were to
give you a dishwasher that actually
helps you gearshift between these
different appliances so that actually
improves your perceptions a lot so there
are ways that we found that actually are
able to correct people's misperceptions
of energy use sort of circumventing
teaching people basic energy physics you
guys with me so far yeah okay great
[Music]
you